today we have three speakers
we have been ruined she's the chair in
the chair and digital information at the
information and communication science
department at the free university of
brussels his research focuses on
metadata in the cultural heritage sector
and documentation practices and watch
alone and private bodies he also worked
as a consultant on the top of divisional
cultural heritage and is active as a
trainer in the demeanor record and
document management for the european
commission says is also a member of the
dublin core metadata industry dublin
core metadata initiative advisory boards
and then we have at the farm there is
max we build up max as a PhD candidate
and teaching assistants in the
information
technologies department as a free
university of brussels he has a master
degree in statistics and advanced degree
in computational linguistics currently
is writing his dissertation on the
impact language extraction undocumented
treatment and we also have before Reuben
is a researcher at the multimedia lab at
Ghent University and also with the
interdisciplinary Institute before that
technology his interests include
semantic web technologies multimedia
annotation artificial intelligence and a
relationship on TV new processing
currently he is working on with a
welcoming the algorithms to the web and
on associated problems such as effective
service descriptions today they will be
speaking about the research project for
your metadata clock thank you very much
Robbie and first of all thank you very
much for having us here at Columbia
think Ruben max and myself are very much
excited to be here and talk to you today
about our research project for metadata
so today we will discuss how we can use
technologies and tools to augment
metadata quality and throughout our work
but also today in our presentation we
really attached a lot of value to
hands-on practice and the
experimentation with data and
technologies and this is really kind of
a result or an outcome of a serving the
sometimes this delicate dance that you
probably all know between users and
technologies or tools so like in the
context of an iphone you're using an
iphone but sometimes may seem like the
iphone is actually using you and this
also just really applies to the context
of semantic web or digital our and
linked data in the sense that as
librarians or people working in the
cultural heritage sector we have been
discussing this over lunch sometimes we
have the impression that all of these
technologies are kind of imposed upon us
or that sometimes the implementation and
you
of a technology becomes an end in itself
whereas it is quite important though it
remains a mean to an end and here i
would like to kind of briefly point out
what we could learn from artists and a
couple of months ago in Belgium in
Brussels I had the opportunity to have a
look at the work of Evan Roth who's a
thing he's natively from Detroit or in
New York he's an extremely smart young
us artist really works on this struggle
between users and users and tools and
really I tries to find out through his
installations and his work where's the
the sweet spot where users take again I
put themselves back into the driving
seat and take again power over their
tools its way kind of funny because I
just found it exactly the same object by
this plastic strap which Evan Roth uses
in a couple of installations in his work
and especially here this video it's a
very short video how to keep nasty
people from putting their seats back dot
com I highly recommend you to have a
look at it it just lasts for 30 seconds
but this is a very nice smart made
installation to make you reflect about
at the end of the day we just have a
goal to achieve and we don't really care
or actually we just want the easiest the
cheapest the most straightforward tool
to really to get to our goal but
unfortunately sometimes in the context
of the Semantic Web or complex
technologies that's for the moment not
really the case but so here I would just
like to point out a short quote of one
of the first researchers who worked as a
kind of an anthropologist of technology
and France Jacques video release s and
this is this goes very much into the
direction of this user empowerment's in
the work of Evan Roth so for the user
the purpose of the machine is not to
make the machine work but to make it
work in the surface of something
has nothing to do with technology so at
bottom line is at the end you just have
a goal as user you want to do something
and you don't really care with the type
of technology that you're using however
in the context of libraries we're all
and we were talking about this again
over lunch obviously we really as a
community we want to make the most out
of technology and we need to push the
technology technological advance as
widely as possible but in this
discussion of the the power struggle
between users and technologies and tools
I thought that's this quote from the
Library of Congress Working Group on
bibliographic or on the future of public
graphic control was quite elusive off
again this kind of finding the balance
between users and technologies in the
sense that I'll just quickly read
through the quotes so the library
community will realize that
bibliographic data need to support a
variety of user but also management and
machine needs so it will be recognized
that human users do not represent the
only use of bibliographic data instead
to an increasing degree machine
applications are their primary users so
he really at this situation or the
scenario where sometimes as library
users but also asks catalogus as people
who are working in libraries this is
sometimes the point where we get a bit
uncomfortable and this is exactly the
the point that we try to make with our
project to really to point out how it is
simple and straightforward manner we can
use technologies which might sound quite
complex as linked data concepts and
semantic web because I don't know how
many people here in the room know this
video the Jeffrey Beal production I
always show it to my students in the
first class on the metadata no one has
seen this ah but basically it's a very
cynical video which makes a very much
fun of our whole research project order
the concept of semantic web
link data and in a way I think this
video was created a year or two years
ago and in a way I can entirely agree I
agree upon this vision which is put
forward in the video in the sense that
here we just have to catalog which we're
discussing the use or the of the
Semantic Web and the context of the
library we're at the end of the story
they just agree that basically it's
utterly unclear and only consultants are
kind of getting money on imposing this
visionary the the importance of making
use of semantic web standards but so our
whole talk is in a way kind of a reply
to this kind of a cynical vision
sometimes on how technologies are
promoted or imposed upon cultural
heritage institutions so here we really
get back to the fundamental point of a
project so first of all and this is
really a something which will be
explained in detail by my colleague max
all metadata are our messy so it's
extremely important to have look at
tools which you can use to kind of
diagnose the the quality of your of your
metadata and the 10 or 15 years I have
been working in the field I've never
received an export of a museum or
library which was completely clean so
it's just kind of a common stance or a
common ground which we should assume for
our project and for the publication we
worked on this summer we're extremely
happy to use or it wasn't obvious for us
to find an export of metadata upon which
we could work and so we're very happy to
cooperate with the people of the
Powerhouse Museum which have had over
the past and will have also in the
future a very progressive vision on
publicly making available their data and
it's also a very nice example of what
actually happens or what other people
start doing once you put out your your
own made data and last of all the third
element and that's what my colleague
Ruben will focus on
there are there is a whole exciting
world of possibilities which emerge
emerged once you get your local
vocabularies reconciled with elements
which are already part of the linked
data cloud such as live with Congress
subject headings but again we're really
show in a very hands-on manner how this
this all works but so this was just a
very general introduction of the the
theme and the the content of the the
presentation but so the really the bulk
of the the talk of today will consist of
a very practical overview of how to use
Google refine for metadata cleaning and
reconciliation and then at the end
really hope or apparently are Robbie and
their colleague already told us a bit
about some issues that were perhaps
present in some digital library projects
really hope that at the end of the talk
we can discuss about the specific
problems you have and which way our work
could eventually help to to enhance some
of your metadata but so from a
methodological point of view the the
first step is really to use as a common
ground that all metadata are messy and
therefore it's extremely important to
analyze to try to gather a diagnosis of
the quality issues your collection is
faced with then the second step is to go
towards standardization and
normalization again will show a lot of
concrete examples on how to do that and
then the last step which is in a way
fundamental here is the whole
reconciliation or the mapping of your
local vocabularies with elements which
are already part of the linked data
clouds but so before I give the floor to
max I would just like to briefly talk a
bit about this notion of quality again
we were just an hour ago talking about
this fundamental problem of how to
define quality because at the end of the
line
for example i saw this ISO 9000 standard
which is used by the industry just
basically defines quality as fitness for
purpose a lot of engineers IT people or
for example this whole total data
quality management program at MIT from
the 90s these people had really quite a
deterministic fish in the pond koala
upon quality where is it we're living in
a pimpy racal world which keeps on
moving through our time so at no point
in time it's really fundamentally
possible to say are in a binary way
something is correct or not so that's
why it's important to realize that
quality is fundamentally relative and
this gets back to the the second sense
of meta in metadata people always think
about metadata or major in meta data as
being on a more abstract level which is
the first sense but it's also very
important to think about the second
sense that made the house which is the
notion of change so metastasis or for
example refers to this fundamental
notion of evolution to our time and this
gets us back to really the importance of
using a tool such as Google refine we
also have other types of tools to really
systematically and throughout I'm make
snapshots of how your metadata are
evolving and so for those of you are
interested in this topic I just
published with my colleague is available
dense a paper on this in the Journal of
documentation last year but so now let's
just get our hands into the more
practical parts and so I'll give the
floor to max who will now really talk
about the first fundamental step which
is clean okay so yes let's go more
practical I have only one slide I'll be
true to you then so in order to
implement all those those nice
methodologies set was talking about were
be making use of a tool called Google
refine which is a free app which can be
used to improve the quality of metadata
and it's quite multifunctional as we
said before there are several steps I'm
going just back to show them yeah this
three essential steps first to diagnose
quality issues then to improve the
quality and reconcile the main advantage
of Google refine is that you can perform
all three steps in a single interface
which is quite handy okay like to my one
snider and so I'll I hope to prove today
that it's a very easy tool and that we
can perform all those different
operations in there and in order to
insist on the the fact that it's a tool
very easy for any user I won't use any
screencasts but instead I'm performed
some metadata freeing live on stage are
you here with the directly in the Google
refine interface so you notice it's a
bro browser interface but it's still
local so it's run on your machine you
don't have to upload all your metadata
and share them with Google which it's
not what we want so it's in the browser
interface but it's run locally so
starting from scratch here I can load a
new dataset to create a new Google
refine project and yep
I shoes here the powerhouse museum
collection which is freely the free to
download on their website so this five
here you can get also just googling per
house and you can bro from at home on
your own computer all these operations
with Google refine which is free okay so
I just load this file and create its
full quotation marks yeah okay I just
have to check this box and create
project which takes a few seconds okay
here we are and you see we have about
75,000 objects in their described in
this powerhouse museum collection so the
first thing is to have a good overview
of of the data in there to have a look
at them to get to know your data so
there are a number of different fields
IDs text fields like Oh object titles
descriptions also numbers if you go
further to the right we have dates also
categories which will be really very
interesting to use that those are
keywords from controlled vocabularies
links or so and dimensions and so on and
so on so all those data are from a whole
variety of formats and we'll see now how
we can first establish diagnosis of
what's what's okay in there and what are
the potential metadata problems and then
how we can improve them in the same
interface
so let's start with the record IDs
obviously all objects in the collection
should have 90 so here first operation
I'll create a facet and as I these are
numerical values it's an Emmerich faucet
so I create create that and we refine
finds out there that nearly all ids are
never acquiesce pected we don't have
blank values but we have non numeric
values only three but that's strange so
let's have a look at them and in fact
there are non-numeric because they're
black so why are aren't there here are
listed as blank it's because we have a
single white space here so okay it's as
if they were blank and that's already
problem so we don't have anything here
we just have blank raus so we can remove
them because they're meaningless ok so I
remove those three matching robes and
I've already performed an operation so I
had first i diagnosed that there was a
small problem it's very easy of course
three rows were blank and I already
removed them without affecting the
original collection so the file i loaded
is remains unchanged but the project
loaded into Google refine is changed and
at the end I can export it to have a new
file with the quality improved and if
you do any mistake there's a nice
history of undo/redo here so you can
always try and change things you can
always go back with a kind of time
machine here that's nice too
okay so next step we've been removing
blank cells but maybe there are so
duplicates in their objects of figuring
twice or more in the collections in
order to see this we'll have to sort the
objects by IDs these are numbers so I
check numbers and smooth first that's
perfect okay let's solve them and in
order yeah the sorting should not be a
temporary it should be made permanent so
I just check here reorder this Rose
permanently I want them to stay in
that's older okay now if two objects in
a row have the same ID that's because
they're duplicates so to see this I'll
blank down another operation lying down
all consecutive objects having the same
idea I blind them down and I immediately
see a t4 cells were affected here on the
top so we'll have a look at those cells
having a new kind of facets and
customized customized facets we have
fasted by blank to find blank values and
foremost objects it's false they're not
blank but 84 of them are blank so we'll
have a look at them here they don't have
any record ID because it was blank down
so how do we how could we be sure these
are duplicates we can by switching
between those two views here in Google
refine have the rouse view just one row
44 yeah every different different row
but we can also switch to wear a records
view which
I'll be doing now and here we have a
clear view that we had duplicate here
those two objects are exactly the same
titles is the same day registration
number also and so on and so on so by
switching to this records view I'm sure
this were real duplicates that can be
removed from the collection so I switch
back to the other view and I choose to
remove all matching rows also okay so no
it should be okay but still let's have
another facet of blank facets on the
registration number and we see that over
100 are still blank is because the
Heather record ID but that's all we only
had an idea and nothing else so that's
not a gravity issue here are some
objects in collections were awarded an
ideal but there's nothing corresponding
to this idea and we're not interested
obviously in those objects right now we
should of course in a real well check
why those IDs were attributed here we
don't need them so I can also remove
them I remove all matching rods okay so
we only worked with numbers but of
course we can look at something else
like the production dates dates should
be number as well so i will check that
with an numeric facet and we we can see
most most objects are blank for that
felt here I don't know if if you see it
it's grey but yes 755 thousands objects
don't have data at all so that's also an
issue and in the remaining ones lots of
them are non-numeric which is strange
for dates we can see why it's because
they use or they also use ranges okay so
in the same field here we have no
integrity constraint we have ranges with
two different dates and we have real
single dates as well in the same color
okay that's another interesting thing to
notice one yeah one more example here
with the dimensions if I do a blank
facets for example on the hate-filled
field okay I ignore those that are blank
but the other ones most of them here are
expressed in millimeters so if we look
yeah it's always millimeters but i'll
use another tool the text filter to see
if other units are used as well for
instance centimeters and yes only eight
objects were not expressed in
millimeters but in centimeters instead
so that that's also a problem there's no
reason why those eight objects should be
expressed in another units okay we could
correct them but I wonder this right now
yeah and so on you can perform all kind
of analysis uh no other fields here for
instance the weights field almost every
yeah almost no object has hate only less
than 200 have one so is this it feels
really yeah do we need this
this fields if so few objects have a
hates included in the system okay but
now i go for to the more interesting
parts I already talked before that's the
categories okay the categories I told
you where our keywords from controlled
vocabularies and you can see here that
several key words are put together in
the same cell so they are separated by
the pipe character here the first object
is classified under botanical specimens
but also numismatics two different
keywords separated by the pipe character
so the first thing we need is to split
those keywords but but but at the same
time keeping all of them links to the
right object we can we can do this with
Google refine with another operation in
edit cells we have splits multivalued
cells up I'll do this I have to select
the right character to separate and it's
the pipe character so that's okay
working for a few seconds
okay that's it so whereas we have before
we had 75 thousand objects know we have
much more routes here you can see a
hundred and seventy thousands that's
because for a single object they can be
many different keywords but if we switch
back to the records view we still have
the same number of records it doesn't
change we then didn't change anything
and the the keywords are linked to a
single object okay now the most
interesting thing is that we can have a
text facet we didn't use that yet
because we didn't use text fields if we
do a text facet we'll ask Google refine
to list all different values possible
values used in the collection all
different keywords and they are listed
here on the right there are just under
five thousand key words used to describe
objects in this collection and we can
sort them by count to get the more
popular keywords here we can see
numismatics is the most used followed by
ceramics clothing and dress and so on
okay and there are lots of them and I
will use this cluster functionality just
here to see if keywords are duplicates
or near duplicates and that's a powerful
functionality of google refine because
here you can see that two different
categories were used just before because
of different in case or space or
something okay and we can have a look at
that obviously it's always the same here
documents with or without capital letter
and so on and so on and
that's a cat here we just diagnose a
problem but we can solve it at the same
time by selecting ok I select everything
and I want to merge everything together
so those two different those two
variations will be merged to this one on
the right and you can change if you
don't like what Google refine use as the
default so up I select that and in less
than seconds it was done and thirty
seven thousand cells were edited so
that's cool ok and we have different
methods to to cluster them together we
can switch to another one friend for
instance and Graham fingerprints here
which is more aggressive sort of and you
yeah it's a good way to remind you that
Google refine is the tool but you're the
master because we will refine can make
mistakes and here you have to to yeah to
to have a good look because if we select
everything the Google refine would be
making a mistake can you see that by
merging things together don't you yeah
shirts and t-shirts exactly so shirts
and t-shirts are very similar but
obviously they're not really the same so
why we could argue can argue that they
could fit in the same category but here
we have two distinct categories so we
can select everything to merge unless
shirt and t-shirts we keep them apart
and we re cluster everything okay
moral things are merged we have even
more aggressive techniques but I won't
use them just to show you because it's
yeah it's but thats and let us know and
things like that I have other funny
examples I think dresses and pressor so
you have to be careful of course nuts to
let Google refine do anything the user
has to remain and Oh what else okay
wallets and mallets and so on and so on
yes honey okay so I I won't be merging
that and here we've already reduced the
number of categories used because we
cluster them together still of course
there's always the problem of having a
very specific categories used only for
one or two objects that's another
problem we can't solve anything for
instance here we have that's very
interesting category toy rabbits of
course there are not so many category
not so many objects in the collection
corresponding to that keyboard but it
should have if I run text filter I if
it's okay it should have fit in toy
animals maybe which is how more general
so still there there are other problems
but the cluster functionality is a good
way to have a first and very quick and
efficient clustering to improve the
quality okay no I'll give the match to
ribbon was going to go through the next
step which is reconciliation
no I've not been to the Museum of Modern
Art's yet I plan to do it so what have I
been drawing here then well sadly this
is the current metadata landscape this
is how it works now it's all islands
every collection is in its own Island
there's a powerhouse museum somewhere
there's larger collections there are
also smaller collections but the general
thing is they're all islands and what we
really want us as metadata people it's
connection that it's all about it's not
about this one collection with it about
how those collections relate to each
other and am basically by just having
metadata cleaned up we're not yet making
those bridges so the next part
reconciliation is going to be about
those bridges it's going to be about how
can we use the metadata to create some
universal sense of meaning to create
metadata that can be shared across
different collections and the idea is
that we're going to use controlled
vocabulary so the vocabulary you've seen
now was more ad hoc vocabulary used by
the powerhouse museum but the porous
museum has its own and other museums
have have different ones so there's no
real interoperability there so what
we're going to use as centralized
vocabulary and that is to link every
collection to that centralized
vocabulary and in that way they'll also
be linked to each other indirectly so
this is what I'm going to show you now
so practically how does that work let me
quickly go to my slides so we will fuse
familiar with LC SH the Library of
Congress subject headings you've heard
about that I assume did you hear good
things about that bad things who says
okay who said it's a good thing it's
everybody great
it has some problems also controlled
vocabularies are not having yet but they
can be really useful as I'll just show
in a second so the idea of using the LOC
subject headings is not only they are
controlled but they're also accessible
online they're freely accessible so
they're both human readable but also
machine readable so they're also a
machine-readable format accessible
online so let me maybe quickly show you
that on them on the website so this is
the Library of Congress website and
basically you have the different subject
headings over here and some of them are
a specific some of them are really
general but they all have the
relationship to each other so you can
know which one is it the more specific
one of another and so on and the
interesting thing for for us is that you
can also download the whole thing and
once it don't know that you can use it
to reconcile a collection using Google
refine so that's what we've done we've
downloaded it and basically the data
formats they've used as a semantic web
format so who's familiar with the
Semantic Web here and who sets the good
thing that's everybody again that's
right now so am but linked data and
semantic web provide really cool tools
because they're linked together
similarly like collections should be
linked together but they're also
queryable so we just put the whole and
LCS H in a database which we can query
using sparkle and sparkle is basically
the Semantic Web granular language is
like SQL for that semantic web so let me
go back to Google refine and I'll just
use a small clean subset of the power
museum collection so this is the
collection after it has been cleaned
using the steps max has shown and
basically here we're interested in the
categories field of course because this
is the field that other items and other
collections are also going to have so
it's this field we're going to
reconcile to this centralized controlled
vocabulary how does it work well what I
did before is I added the LCS H database
the sparkle database to the system on
the website are the details on how you
can do it yourself but it's all
technical stuff so I won't bother you
with it but the important thing is that
it's really easy to reconcile so I just
go up to categories and I choose
reconcile starter I concerning and then
I choose from which to which M
centralized vocabulary I want to
reconcile in this case the LCS h and
what is doing no it's basically scanning
through all the different types i have
and based on that it will guess what
kind of elements and working with in
this case I'm indeed working with
concepts of course concepts and
basically this is it so now it has a
term and what to do and now i take the
start reconciling button and it just
does what it has to do and one thing you
should notice is that's going really
fast to imagine having to do this all by
yourself on many will I mean my laptop
is currently standing on the LCS stage I
know if you can see it but those big
books are the full thing so if you have
to do many buddy you'd spend hours on
that but no look it's it's already done
in fact oh and what's the difference
well for example em a few minutes ago
there was also botanical specimens here
but it was in black know it and blue
it's linked actually so the thing is if
I click on this I go to the botanical
specimens webpage and what's the
difference well a few minutes ago
botanical specimens was only a text and
it had meaning to us because you
understand English but machines don't
but thanks to this link it no also means
something to machines it not just let us
be OT and so on it's really disk a
degree of LCS h and this category is
also used by other fur and vocabularies
and by other collections so this is a
whole world of difference and this will
actually enable the coupling and the
interaction of different collections
together and this is it so this was
really really fast and
this is really powerful so don't be
misled by the speeds Google refine
because because this is really an
important concept if you want to do the
integration thing and I think this is
what we all should be working towards so
I'll just most important parts website I
don't know like regarding the
reconciliation I don't know if I hands
voila so just the process that Ruben was
just demonstrating five minutes ago was
anyway extremely powerful but to take
for example I probably a best example
would be in a geographical area so let's
suppose that we had won a record about
some object in Buenos Aires if we if you
just have the the meaningless text
string it's obvious to you as humans
that Boras areas is a part of Latin
America or a capital in Latin America
but from a moment on that you perform
this reconciling with an authoritative
Larry you also automatically a attract
or import the whole hierarchy of the
different concepts so we would also once
you have performed a reconciliation if a
user for example the zoo lock look up on
Argentina or Latin America after the
reconciliation that user will also find
the records with Argentina so that's
really a fundamental aspect of this
whole reconciliation process but so all
of the things which we have been talking
about during this presentation are in a
way completely available on the website
so if you want to have look at Max's
dynamic cleaning
and you can't or you just want to repeat
the same steps on the data set of the
powerhouse museum so here you have a
very detailed explanation of all of
these steps and we've been really glad
that different people have been using
these sets within their metadata classes
or within universities with students and
also regarding the reconciliation here
also again you have all the different
steps this can be a bit more technical
especially regarding the identifying the
LCS age as a reconciliation source but
as you perhaps already or also saw
within the interface you could also just
easily take for example dbpedia or I
don't know what the other or freebase
are just default reconciliation short
sources which you can just you can just
take a box next to them and then see for
example so with the powerhouse data
collection we had eighty percent of
reconciliation success but you could
also have a look at what happens for
example if you try to reconcile those
terms with for example dbpedia or
freebase so those were probably the most
important steps to have a look at so for
us as researchers it's very important to
have access to interesting and as messy
as possible data we're mated eight so if
you have that made the data please do
not hesitate to send them to us it
allows us to write the interesting
papers about and so now for the moment
we're working with Jill Hamilton of
National Library of Scotland I'm not
saying they have bad may today they're
actually very very interesting with
Lucas on five or six different levels
they are using authority Authority files
in a very detailed manner so probably
over the next few months will develop a
case study based upon their date
but that will mainly focus on the
reconciliation especially for the
metadata cleaning part really still
looking for probably we should just
launched competition on the website so
the people that send us the messiest
made the data will get the t-shirts or I
don't know will will get a price or para
but so this was really kind of a very
global approach of what's the project
about what's the whole methodology and
then now for us one of the more
interesting parts of getting here to the
US and to Colombia would be really to
see how in a way you think that the
mythology or Google refiner the whole
reconciliation approach could be
valuable towards you so I would be more
than happy to just I don't know in which
form it we could organize the discussion
voila but perhaps first of all people
have some specific questions regarding
the cleaning or the reconciliation yes
we've all golden
characters yeah but klaxons
actually only one day at university of
ireland we next working unico suture we
didn't
s squared you say eighty percent and
their son by 87 any person pretty
familiar with what my version 1.0 I
exactly it's the perrito law that with
eighty percent we get eighty percent of
your results with twenty percent of what
your efforts but to get the rest of the
twenty percent you need to spend eighty
percent of your effort yeah but anyway
yeah it haven't really thought about
that for that's a thing you should feel
this way really I listed just assume
that that everything working reconcile
this message gets to but what you mean a
tea person can be and it's summer for
can be
and only a student 20 persons and
developers and yes this will be the more
difficulties of course of information
but you only have to deal with us so but
in a way I don't think it's it's not
really the goal to have like a hundred
percent reconciliation that all they are
I from me personally I never expected
that we would have managed to get to to
that level but so just having a
completely automated match for eighty
percent of the objects of the so in
total we almost had eighty thousand
records with quite a big surprise to us
all the easy cases for you digital cases
and eat your concentration
I agree and I me astray it is a part of
times so I work in large our collections
i do are awesome so I just so until I
should exchange thing I get an eight
percent I'm very quickly how do you do
your quality control no that is yeah so
this whole project is kind of based on a
paper we've written over the summer
which is currently in review but so here
in this paper you'll find the whole
methodology which we used to analyze the
the quality of the wii conciliation
process so the first thing we did is
just to take a big sample so i
personally spent probably a week in july
when the sun was shining outside my
office the to really have a look at to
see i really expected to find a lot of
synonyms or only our problems relating
to bali see me but for the five four or
five hundred records which i manually
analyzed no single records provided a
false match so I really expected to find
examples of what's a policy name for
example ha there's an example in the
paper I for example how would would can
be interpreted as the material or as
woods the park but the huge advantage of
the LCS a LCEs H is that they never use
any ambiguous terms within their
collection so from the moment on that
you have a match it's also a
disadvantage in the sense that for a lot
of terms which I thought would vary were
very easy to reconcile like cup a cup
wasn't reconciled because cup in a way
can have multiple significant TSA's so
in with
when I was analyzing these 500 terms I
just I wasn't able I in a way I was very
disappointed because I hope to find some
rare examples to just to prove that
there were sometimes some some
misunderstandings but I was completely
unable to find a record with which was
falsely matched so that was the first
approach just a manual a look up and
then Ruben worked on a kind of a
methodology to see how deeply the the
terms are actually matched I think we
would all agree that if we just speak
about terms like church or woods or a
table and you manage to reconcile that
all librarians would say are okay fair
enough but even if you with automatic
image recognition probably machine can
detect a person or like low level
semantics within an image or in a
document but so we developed this method
to see how deeply embedded within the
structure of LCS h-word the terms
reconciled to really see that a lot of
these terms and for example rabbits what
was it rabbit toy you really have lots
of extremely detailed semantics which
have been reconciled if you want to have
more kind of details on that whole
methodology just have a look at paper
which is online on on the website it's a
very important question how to analyze
the quality of the reconciliation in a
way it's kind of just very populist to
say are we managed to reconcile eighty
percent it's a very important questions
from those eighty percent are we
speaking about important terms or just
about low level semantics but in this
case study we really found out that a
lot of the the reconcile terms were
actually very useful for information
retrieval or for their use of the terms
that defined objects to a no pack
yes
using representative yes
all let's all stats in your words but
complete and social stigma to flames
labels and they're all week so this is a
compensation well maybe things and then
information with all the alternates
alternates as well and as far as they
didn't conflict we prefer because math
EF synonyms and so on
the sentence for the Albert labels they
don't so we only was unconscious them
effectively causing smaller if Ragosa
nation live achieve doesn't disrespect
me strength but what was the difference
in animals are suspects it's about it
was at least 30
alternatives are people
so data set is there a practical use
Malcolm it didn't cheat that data are
they go
or United see where he had
rabbit
we're going to meet Sebastian channel
next week oh it's a lot lam event hosted
by the new york public library on the
22nd or 23rd and over the next few
months we going to work on an extension
for the Chrome browser which once the
user installs the distance extension and
you're on the web page of a collection
database and having a look for example
at the rabbit toy that you just have
automatically and on the fly a pop up on
your screen saying ah so apparently you
are interested in rabbit toys it's
important to know that in this
collection database you have an object
which is identified by exactly the same
subject heading so probably this object
will also be to interest the view and so
this is this would be a very practical
kind of added value towards end users
and we're also in parallel working I
don't know if any one of you knows the
this open-source collections management
system collective access over the last
few years I've worked together with them
and so we've been thinking about how
linked data could also just help
catalogers in the sense that within the
cataloging backends also on the fly when
you start typing in certain terms
there's already within collective access
kind of you can activate web services to
have on the fly when you type in rapid
toy it already kind of automatically
pops up the subject heading but then a
second element on which we would like to
work is then if it finds a rabbit soy in
LCS age and it also has a look at the
documentation or the the metadata which
have been added in other collections and
which is just have to work on how we're
going to display this information in a
pop-up or in a user interface that it
also just shows all of the metadata
related to that type of objects from
other collection databases so as a
cataloger when you described in
object that in a very quick and very
intuitive manner you see our I'm
describing this object which has already
been described by the other people in
other museums perhaps there are elements
which I can reuse so that would be kind
of an added value towards catalogers but
uh so over the next two to three months
we're all kind of busy working on those
two those two steps but so for us it's
extremely important to have access to to
metadata from cultural Heritage's
heritage sector so if there are people
amongst you who are interested in this
whole field and want to collaborate with
us please absolutely do not hesitate to
contact us and would be more than happy
to work together over the next few
months the would hopefully be a good
thing for your collection or for your
policy but would also just be very
helpful for for us to have solid data to
work with while developing these tools
and while writing papers but so I do any
persons here in the room who would think
that all of these kind of steps would be
of immediate use their collection and if
so how are half have any of you worked
with other tools or developed some made
data quality methodologies or steps and
if so how have you done them or
performing them in your institution
I'm Theresa the export to export
I
hood
Magnus
there's an expert so you have altered
the traditional formats that's a temp
service models
what's interesting to us as semantic web
be good as if you can go back to RTF
format solutely this is also an
advantage because you don't have
semantically enriched it as a semantic
schematic little later with beauty of
refining haces open source and that
several plugins exist in fact erdf is
not entertain their answer we can be
identical way so you can have to plug
into a different format so you can
easily plug in existing but what is
fairly complex but also from research
wise very interesting for us is now that
we've been collaborating with the people
of the National Library in Scotland that
they have a very complex highly complex
relational database in which they're
using eight or nine different
vocabularies or controlled vocabularies
but then for us or Google refine just
needs a flat file lists you can't really
export or feed it SQL or some relational
format you need kind of just flatten it
and this from a match methodological
point of view so max I kind of annoyed
him over the last few weeks when we were
preparing for this trip to try to
manipulate it really to flatten this big
export that we received from scotland's
and to kind of push it down to something
which we could feed into a Google refine
but we were obliged to kind of simplify
the semantics before I simplifying the
other values of that database in order
to put it into Google refine but
obviously it's a bit bizarre or we
actually had to talk the whole goal of
the project is to add semantics but in
order to do do so we had the kind of to
simplify the very rich formats in which
it originally exists so there's a whole
complexity of kind of getting the data
in to flatten it to get into Google
refine in a way it would be better to
find a way to get it google refinery
something else
automatic or automatically incorporated
within your workflow or within your
repository so you don't have to kind of
flatten things before you will perform
all these operations nation is also
possible and also made an error shinobi
performed all steps manually but you can
just record your steps and just play
them back to me
have you given any thought to your only
working with right now with taco
subjects have you given any thought to
clean up of data dealing with names so
hopefully on the twenty-third the new
york public library will also just
experiment with name authority files or
day but for example with within this
export we received from scotland's there
are a lot of fields related to a names
of organizations historical figures but
for the moment the kind of the big
experiment we did with the powerhouse
data does not really includes
unfortunately names or dates and also
things in ages so refined what
originally and product codes and
previously written books papers from
three quests of freebase integrations
freebase happens to help us use every
person so if you want to do personal
recreation of the three bases in the
world
because its native
I work at the Museum are
installations men
for each department
now
consolidate
as what my system are you were
integrating everything well it'll be
slow because customs is a new building
houses used on pressing national teams
just ripped my swell got balls basics
back yards against Tennessee basically
it's a proprietary signal based
and doesn't National
great so much what you're doing here
one of the video of course is that you
might be in by the same name that the
these days
I was wondering how the system 5
circular multi
more
veterans replaces may be celebrating
that Harrison Jordan of Paris France we
need seven bills are those the preceding
mouth welcome it's great second or third
browser right well brochure you can do
so much smarts drinks their blankets you
need you again
of course the big story wouldn't it be
as you do multi cologne reconciliation
which is possible as it's implemented
inside to refine good days and then
softly reconciliation tools can use it
the re an extension doesn't have any
habits I think our plans implementing
this because the entity to need to our
donita PS best post personally meet with
the similar or the same eight but you
also have that this say that the
authorship of the word maybe then it
should be possible to do these things
and would be difficult thanks
so sure announcer it's really possible
it is already party possible stay tuned
not really well known but the Library of
Congress name for a file ID
there are one of the formats available
those mats are da bush actually parse
out fast
separately
if you use that
most all four
trying to a policy as you know one
authority
different terms and annually because I
think because the sparkle burden is
inflexible super though think it would
be good idea to redo it at the same time
well I will have personally do exactly
duplicates codes such as has the pickets
of different governance and then each
column try to work together you want and
then you can do I'm just speaking my
institution our challenges
museum objects books library collections
archive election for mineral objects and
each of those is
so which is really problematic for
single search interface
subjects you have a basement
search and so our strategy right now is
basically tackling notes thankfully one
by one said about not nice
the library if there was a way to
automate that process it would be I
didn't sure that the ders rather we will
refine expression language to deal with
regular expression sense very easy
portal 2 to tweak to use more specific
operations
so back to the profile extrusion line
definitely kind of you know it out use
my knowledge is there any way that
non-expert time was it Chris find out
what those expressions are already
excited who else was there said its
first is effective that's true that's
one of the things I it doesn't offend
someone explain to me I can't explain
anything in a very difficult to
understand but that's not worth two
cents worth of assets is mainly will be
five basics in an understandable way I
think you could do the same for the
expression language because the rats
could advertise fashions that are used
all the time that are just you explain
and since their economy because also you
should just provide patient with colon
expressions and a very difficult
so you don't even have to understand
fully understand what they do you can
just use them at this one that's it
yeah but again then our nation's reading
top 10 most used if you have a problem
exactly how should this just as we do
you can also just say problems but it's
just a general email address yes you
stay Oliver's so if you can just move in
flu activity adjusts the first means
deceiver oh yeah sorry good girl so it's
a few miss the day to the pork / fear
may still be here
everything is on there is under words
and so but I probably already I just saw
that I actually skipped four slides at
the end but so uh I I won't bore you
with a lot of extra information but uh
was it actually something I yeah but
actually this good kind of wrap up a bit
the talk in a way the whole goal is kind
of to get back here to this this notion
of empowering users to to get to grips
with with tools and we hope just by
having demonstrated so quite a simple
but also still a powerful tool ask
Google refine to be how catalogus
librarians can really on their own
without the help of any IT experts
really kind of test out the added value
of linked data and semantic web on your
own all right so we hope this has been
interesting and helpful to you and again
would be very motivated to get in touch
with with all of you if you have
interesting data to share with us thank
you